thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even cool
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing
unfortunately I couldn't
[Laughter]
how are you guys doing first of all I
have to apologize to the viewers
how are you guys doing
I know you're wondering
[Laughter]
I know you're wondering why is it that
the quality of your video is reduced
why is it that you are having a worse
off-sensory experience then you'll
usually have in these moments
and the reason why is because we have
the jump next to me you know I know this
is absolutely upsetting to many of the
viewers people with them in the
descriptions we've got the Pakistani
Punk
we've got the uh the man with the plan
the final most influential Men actually
let's let's now let's switch it up okay
he's a man that has been on uh on
YouTube for 10 years a must and Achieve
fix this now yes you do yes you do
achieve more than most have in the in
the industry actually in the Dow
industry I wouldn't go that far yes I
was talking about myself okay
but you don't have the Accolade or the
500 yeah
okay okay
of this woman she's uh faked her you
know these abuse cases
and first of all maybe we should watch a
video bringing it to the public because
it's on mainstream news and then comment
uh after that
this CCTV of Eleanor Williams buying a
hammer in Tesco would be used in court
to prosecute her police say it's what
she used to injure herself in an effort
to support lies that she'd been raped
and battered by multiple men now Miss
Williams has been sentenced to eight and
a half years in jail for perverting the
course of Justice okay so what what do
you think of this
well firstly I think it's a big slap in
the face of the people that have
hijacked this issue and turned it into a
Muslim only issue because it's now come
in the media in Guardian we're talking
about grooming grooming in general
exactly that this was kind of relegated
to an only Muslim issue and it's been
well proven not only has it come out in
the media the guardian report today it's
not a Muslim issue but the home office
has kind of provided the Academia behind
this and concluded as a majority white
issue so those people that have actually
hijacked this they have actually caused
a major issues they have actually made
it worse for the victims because
painting a picture of a groomer to look
a certain way is a big mistake and is a
gross disservice to those victims and in
fact you know there was a case that came
out when I lasted this video that a
policeman was accused of grooming as
well really so if you paint them to be
Asian then what you're doing is you're
allowing other people to perpetrate that
crime under a cloak of invisibility as
it were so what we're seeing now with
Elena Williams using a hammer
self-inflicting that some people are
even saying that she could possibly have
even been leveraged by the far right and
I wouldn't frankly put it past them to
be honest
um that they have been using things that
are of legitimate concern to the British
public and they have actually made a
mockery and the people have suffered and
paid the price because Elena Williams
has
weaponized something and you know what
one individual received 500 death
threats another individual his marriage
was broken other people will abuse their
kids were abused in schools and because
of solidarity with this woman people
putting purple elephants on their
Windows she had merchandise this was a
big issue hijab this was a big big issue
and what these people have done is
sickening is sickening and is disgusting
how such a serious thing has been kind
of turned into like some sort of facade
it's it's a facade and you know what
it's it's now incumbent upon the far
right people that weaponize this to come
out and condemn this otherwise it shows
that you're clearly not genuine
I mean this is something
um I didn't expect such a robust reply I
mean uh maybe because this is one of
your areas you know current affairs
maybe it's because you got the
inspiration from the champ but also
because honestly you know you've made a
series I've had no idea what the stuff
he was talking about now I'll be honest
you know the the purple elephant and
this and that this is it was a big thing
bro but you know let me ask a question
then do you know like for instance
this issue of because this is becoming a
phenomenon now false allegations of
abuse
[Music]
and I was just reading maybe I should
read this to the public bro because this
is something from the gov website right
this is I've seen this uh
new definitions as it were right of what
constitutes this is from the government
yeah government websites
it's basically saying I'm just gonna
summarize that you know abuse abusers
will be given tags and these kinds of
things and there's an emphasis on girls
and women and harassment and all that
kind of stuff so we say okay what kind
of thing are we talking about here
um
let's see what they say in a second
these are some of the measures that are
going to be set out it says the law will
be changed so that the most dangerous
domestic abusers will be watched more
closely for the first time controlling
or coercive Behavior will be put on par
with physical violence now listen to
this here
which will mean offenders sentenced to a
year or more in prison offenders
sentenced to a year or more imprisonment
or a suspended sentence will
automatically actively
managed by the police prison or
Probation Services Under multi-agency
public protection yeah
Arrangement a range of agencies will
have a legal Duty
to
a range of agencies will have a legal
duty to cooperate to manage the risks
posed by the dangerous offenders while
we are pursuing pursuing this
legislation police and Probation
Services will start work immediately to
ensure that from now on offend the
sentence to a year or more for
controlling and coercive behaviors are
recorded on the sex offenders register
so that they don't fall through the
cracks
now what do they mean by
of controlling Behavior bro this is such
a big term it's saying that you can get
a tag on yourself you can use it because
of controlling controlling behavior and
it's going to be put on par
imagine this actually they're gonna put
on par a woman who's maybe been beaten
up by a man like finished off with a
woman who is now maybe the man is
telling her what to do
controlling and coercive behaviors is
going to become law
and it's further being exacerbated by
this whole feminist narrative that
you must listen to all women
yeah any thing that they say you have to
take it so but what they've done is the
natural Justice you know innocent until
proven guilty on in on issues like this
they've actually flipped the script here
bro they've made it guilty until's
proven innocent
if you think about what's going on I
mean what kind of evidence would they
have had to prosecute those innocent
people that now there's clear evidence
that this woman is a liar she's a liar
so whatever this must have had it must
have not been sufficient evidence but
yet they've ruined all these lives
I mean this is what we say when when
Muslims have been treated like this we
say that hate does not discriminate and
governments will find a [__] in the
armor they'll exploit a minority they
will start
with somebody and eventually it will
start becoming arm and general to the
population and this is what we're seeing
this is what we're seeing when it comes
to this as well now trying these sorts
of things on Muslims is now kind of
being spread out and we're seeing this
happening to to men now in general
General yeah it's becoming to to the
normal population to the arm to the
standard population you are now seeing
coercive measures that we as Muslims
have been complaining about and saying
that this is something that you guys
should be assisting Muslims on because
hate does not discriminate and
governments do not stop if their aim and
their kind of objective is control and
to stay in power that's one of their
main things so here because we've
allowed them to do it to Muslims and
minority groups now unfortunately and
sadly we're seeing it done on men women
might be might be on the kind of you
know dry land at the moment but that
water seems uh you know the levels seem
to be rising and I wouldn't put it past
them to eventually engulf the women in
there as well I wouldn't be surprised if
such measures and such discussions and
such a low evidentiary bar
would actually increase
physical violence in households since
now you're equating controlling Behavior
with physical violence then the man may
think well I might as well just slap
this woman rather than say a bad word to
her because if I say the f word to the
woman it's it's as good as me slapping
now so I might as well just slap her
face that's possible bro but you know
what I think it's also going to do is
it's actually going to demean the
sanctity of what a relationship actually
is let alone even what our marriage is
because that woman can now basically
make any kind of control allegation if
if the man tells a woman what to do if
imagine this now so according to this
it's conceivable
right from a legal perspective this
scope that if a man tells a woman you
know do this when we get that from me
get this it can be deemed as controlling
Behavior and the man can be on the sex
offenders register and we'll have a tag
on his body a woman could be in a bad
mood she could be wrong she could
apologize later as we've seen the case
with other issues in which you know it's
it's been revealed after 10 years the
man's been in prison for 10 years and
now you're saying just because
um a command is seen as controlling
suddenly that guy could be put on a
register his risk his earnings can be
taken from him his life can be rude I
don't know what that what they're
thinking and then what they're thinking
bro no I'll tell you what they're
thinking it says discriminatory law
anyway it's a discriminatory law but
then how can you in that same breath
then be surprised and look down upon red
pill
because the more you're trying to force
this narrative the more you're forcing
people to go on you're making you're
actually creating an extreme reaction
which actually acts as a corrective and
to this behavior and we've seen this as
a Muslim Community when they were
invading our countries it caused like
statistically speaking the more drone
attacks there are the more extremists
are born from that area there's a direct
correlation so now we're seeing the the
same thing over here what you're doing
is you're facilitating something and
then you're being surprised with the
results and you're trying to suppress it
even in schools you're not allowed to
mention you know certain uh you know
people like Andrew Tate here in the UK
or snico in in America I mean it's it's
like you're between a rock and a hard
place absolutely and that's why I mean
we mentioned it before but you know
ipsos uh part of King's College London
they did a a survey on on basically
Millennials and gen Z
and they've found that I think 52 of gen
Z and 53 of Millennials males feel like
feminine has not only gone too far but
it's now starting to discriminate
against men and 41 of women in that
study said the same thing when you read
a law like this bro which is saying that
if your country if you have a
controlling Behavior they want to put
this through to into the legislature
into into the I should say the statute
books but imagine that role like all
you're doing is creating more people
that resent
what you're doing to them because you're
just equipping people that could
otherwise be just victim players with
the most ridiculous kind of equipment or
a ridiculous kind of uh of abilities
here
you know what you're also doing you're
taking away respect like respect to men
is love yeah if men don't get respect if
they are not able to become leaders of
their homes they're not able to kind of
lead the ship then that ship is without
a sailor and that ship can literally go
anywhere can crash anywhere and all
those people on board will suffer and
will struggle and this is going to
create men that are going to walk on
eggshells we're worried about the simple
Behavior that's going to create super
Sims that's actually going to create but
you know all about that because when you
looked in the mirror
but you're right thank you so much for
your contributions and I think people
now
um they are gravitating towards Islam as
a religion brought 10 20 years ago I
would handle this 10 20 years ago I'll
be honest I felt like we were way more
in the back foot when it comes to the
gender issues today because the full
fruits of feminism have been finalized
we are starting to see like this is a
rubbish ideology which is breaking
societies even people outside of our
community saying let's just go back to
the tradition that's worked for
thousands of years of human civilization
and Islam is embodying that in probably
the most uncompromising way today and
that's why people are coming into Islam
ten years ago people were never coming
into Islam because of women's rights
issues now people are coming into Islam
because of women's rights issues people
are saying this is but this is more of a
model which is feasible this is more of
a model which is operational this is
more of a model which favors men favors
women favors families and that's why
alhamdulillah that many people have
converted after Andrew takes conversion
and so on and what I'll say is uh this
that thank you for uh you know for
coming on board and seeing it I wish I
could say it was my pleasure but uh
honestly it wasn't my pleasure
have you heard that kind of comment
before no no I'm the one I'm the one who
turned super Sip and uh yeah I've made
out right now
because I was inspired by the the one on
my right
well the thing is
um
with that we'll conclude I'll give you
the last word
since of course
um
I have nothing to add basically like you
or your existence this planet that's
poor bro that's poor
I can't okay
foreign
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale